From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
Today, of the Southern World History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill,
I am in New Orleans, Louisiana, to film an interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress, the Smithsonian's National Museum of African-American History and Culture,
our videographer is John Bishop, and Missy Lane Nichols, the project curator from the museum,
is here today with us in New Orleans. We are in the home of Mr. Richard and Mrs. Anne Sobel,
and are here for an interview to touch on Mr. Sobel's curves and turning in some connection to the Tbubbuluza.
And I think that's the quick step. So Mr. Sobel, thank you so much for welcoming us.
We're glad to have you here.
So when you started, I could just have you give a basic sketch of your childhood family and upbringing in New York City.
I grew up in New York City. I lived on the west side of Manhattan. My father was a lawyer. My mother was a mathematics teacher
and one of the high schools in New York.
I went through schools in New York. I went to the Bronx High School of Science, and I went to college,
a union college, and was connected in New York, and came back to New York to go to Columbia Law School.
Always had so many to spend at your school?
My father was a lawyer, and I was, it was explained to me earlier on that I was going to be a lawyer, and I accepted that.
Did you, did civil rights come into your kind of active attention as you were visiting with the Law Review while at Columbia?
I wrote something about the Jerry Mander decision of the Supreme Court in Alabama while I was in law school,
which was published. But really the truth is that for the most part I was focusing on the work and so forth until I got out of law school.
If you were, can you just sketch the early career path that you bring into the law?
I went from law school to being a law clerk for Judge Paul Hayes on the United States Court of Appeals for the Second Circuit,
which was a one-year position, and then I came to Washington, and for a few months I worked for a commissioner as a special assistant to a commissioner on the Federal Trade Commission,
and in the spring of 1963 I went to work for, was then a autofotus importer as an associate.
What was then a very small, comparatively small law firm in Washington?
And anticipating at the time that that would be a position to stay with for some time I would imagine.
What were perhaps on it?
Yes, I guess that's true. I had certain illusions about what that firm was all about.
Abe Fortis had just handled a very famous case in the Supreme Court involving the right to counsel in state court criminal proceedings,
and I kind of got the mistake in naive idea that was going to be a lot of that kind of thing at the law firm.
The thermonautiled had been a prominent and representing individuals who have been called before the Macauliffe Committee and other committees along the lines of the Macauliffe Committee,
so I had stars in my eyes about what it was and turned out to be quite different.
Tell me how you first got connected to the Lawyers Constitutional Defense Committee?
In 1964, the spring of 1964, two friends of mine colleagues at Autofotus import a young man like myself,
they came aware and told me about the Lawyers Constitutional Defense Committee, which was sending lawyers in the summer to the South to help with the arrests that is essentially were resulting from all the civil rights activity that was taking place.
I volunteered to go in 1964, but a lot of other people did as well, and I wasn't accepted for the reason that they were looking for lawyers who were admitted in the states,
which these problems were most manifest, and I wasn't my two friends who were admitted in Florida, and they were sent down there.
I was kind of unhappy that I wasn't allowed to do this, and during the course of the following winter, I met the director of the program, Henry Schwartz Child, at the home of one of these two men, and I complained to him about this,
and he promised me that I'd be selected next summer, and I was, and in the summer of 1965, I was, they would send lawyers for three weeks on the lawyers' vacations.
I was told I was going to be included, but I didn't know where, and a letter came that said you assigned a new Orleans Louisiana, which was a big disappointment to me, because I wanted to go to Selma, Alabama, or Jackson, Mississippi, or someplace that I had heard of, where things were happening.
Of course, things were happening here, I just didn't know it.
But that letter changed my life, because I got here the first of August 1965, and I spent my three weeks outlined a little bit in those documents I gave you what I did during those times, but it was very enlightening or weakening for me, because a couple of factors.
One is where I was working in Washington, when there was a case, they'd put four lawyers on it, and sometimes lawyers full-time would work on one case, and the case would take years, and that was kind of the way of life.
Here, things were happening with breakneck speed. When I showed up for work the first day, I asked them what I could do.
They said, drive up to Baton Rouge and meet Murphy Bell. He has a school case he wants to bring, and I did, and I went to Baton Rouge and met this gentleman, who was the key black lawyer in that area for civil rights things, and he said that the people in St. Francisville, Westphalishian of Parish, want to bring a school desigregation case.
I said, fine, and I went up there, and I met them, and I got their names and addresses and consents, and so forth, and went back to New Orleans, and a desigregation case by that school desigregation case by that time was a pretty stock thing.
You get someone else's complaint, and you put the new names in, and I did, and I filed it in Baton Rouge, which is the district for that location.
The judge there was a well-known racist judge named Igor and West, and he would just throw all these cases out in a minute they got there, even though it was established law of the land that these cases were proper cases.
And the day after I filed it, the case was dismissed, and I filed a motion in the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals for a summary reversal of Judge West's decision.
And a week later, the Fifth Circuit reversed the decision and sent it back for the entry of an order. In fact, they told them exactly what order to enter.
So I'd been there for eight days, and I had gotten relief in a school desigregation case in the face, or the worst judge in the South, or practically one of them anyway.
And that was just one of several things I did during three weeks, and I could just see the impact I could have in this situation.
A lot of the lawyers who were being sent down by LCDC were also enjoying the life in New Orleans and bringing their wives and different things that seemed to me a little bit of a messy situation.
And that I came away with the firm idea that what they need is permanent lawyers down there, and not people passing through.
And I was working with the law firm, Collins Douglas and Eli, which is a very important, the most important firm in civil rights law in Louisiana, three young black lawyers who became the attorneys for the Congress of Racial Equality, which was the dominant civil rights organization in Louisiana.
And I became friends with them, we liked each other, and we began to talk about my coming down on a more permanent basis, and one thing led to another at the time.
There was a permanent staff member in Jackson, Mississippi, which was the main office. And over that winter, Mr. Schwartz, child raised the money to have a permanent lawyer in New Orleans.
And I was going to be it, and following summer, I came down as an employee in today.
So that's the summer of 60.
Six.
Let me take you back. It's so interesting to hear you talk about your arrival down here at S first three weeks.
Can you say a little bit about, had you traveled in the South previously?
No. I've gotten as far as Charleston, South Carolina. I know, sightseeing.
You mentioned this impression that's made upon a young lawyer by the experience you just just did.
Getting this bit perversal.
I'm interested also to hear about, as you might recall, the other impressions that you formed earlier, the civil rights context in the South as you saw it when you came in hints in that someone in 65.
Well, the office of Collins, Douglas, and Eli was on the second floor in the 2200 block of Dryad Street.
And then the ground floor in the storefront was the Congress or racial equality office.
So I was meeting all these civil rights workers. So I wouldn't consider myself a civil rights worker.
I was a lawyer doing his law work, but they were all coming through.
People I had heard of and read about and action was taking place everywhere.
Not including Bougalooza. Bougalooza was always the most active place, partly because it's so close.
And it was easy to get in and out. It didn't take two days around trip to do something.
But I met the people, all the people in Bougalooza and Bob Hicks, Gail Jenkins, A.C. Young, or T. Young, many people.
There was an affinity growing up in me.
And I just wanted to be part of it on a more permanent basis than this little snapshot that I got.
And any impression I had that it wasn't civil rights activity in Southern Louisiana was completely dispelled.
I was mentioning in terms of my letter that I got.
And that's where I was my impression.
Tell me a little more about the street black lawyers you met.
There among the first African American lawyers in Louisiana, but not the first.
They're older men who have streets named after them in New Orleans, AP Turo, and the best example.
They were about ten years younger than he was.
Robert Collins, who later became a federal judge, the first black federal judge in the South.
Nils Douglas, who died just a few years ago, and who was probably the most active of the three in terms of the representation to core.
And Lollice Eli, who was still my dear friend, and lives right down the block from here.
They were completely different seeing an Arnold Fordous importer.
They were scraping and making a living. They weren't getting paid much by core.
They were very glad to have the help with the civil rights work, which freed them to do something that made a little money.
They would do the kind of work you do in a poor black neighborhood, automobile accidents, bankruptcies, land law-attentant issues.
But they were having a good time about it.
Every day at the end of the three, the one who had the largest office room was Bob Collins.
Everybody would gather in there. He had a bottle of scotch in his bottom drawer.
People would have a drink and talk about what they did.
It was a very attractive, friendly situation.
Things were very stirring up at Arnold importer.
This was a nice contrast.
Were you a little bit about if you would, some of your first impressions of Bob Collins?
My first word comes to mind as hot.
It was hot and smelly because of the paper mill.
At that time, they were having a meeting every single night.
There was the Bougalus of Otisley and the people who were the forefront with the people I mentioned.
Robert Hicks, Gail Jenkins.
There was a union hall right near Robert Hicks's house.
There was a meeting in a rally every single night.
Activities were planned.
There was a long period of time in Bougalusa.
There was a protest march on Main Street.
The main street, in protested discrimination by the store owners.
I would go on every day after school.
The Civil Rights Act had just passed.
I'll put it this way.
The Title VII of the Civil Rights Act had just come into effect four weeks earlier.
There was a lot of focus on conditions at Crown Zellaback,
which was the major employer in town had four plants
of paper products, boxes, wrapping paper, different things.
One of the things I did during my three weeks that for a summer was to work on the EEOC charge
which was a prerequisite to filing a Title VII action in court.
Meeting a lot of the employees at the plants and hearing what they were doing or what their problems were.
There were things going on in the criminal court.
There were arrests coming out of these marches and arrests for other reasons,
harassment arrests, and there was a city court.
I appeared at least twice in a city court of Bougalusa,
which was completely segregated, and had this very angry judge sitting on the bench.
The first time I appeared, I mean, different to say,
Abe Fortis had just been appointed to the Supreme Court like the week I left.
And Nils Douglas was with me and he stood up and said,
please, the court, I want to introduce to the court Richard Sobel,
who comes from the law firm in Washington, D.C.,
from which the most recent Supreme Court nominee has come.
And this judge used a crutch, one crutch to walk, he took his crutch,
and he slammed it on the table and he said,
don't talk to me about the Supreme Court of the United States.
And that was my introduction to the city court,
but he let me say what I wanted,
and I was before him at least two or three times in those three weeks.
I'm interested to hear a little bit too about some of your first impressions about
some of your first impressions about how it felt for you to be stepping into this landscape personally.
I mean, you mentioned that, aside from the legal side,
did you, was there more complex set of concerns for you to have your safety about?
Well, nothing that happened just before I got here,
was that a bomb had been set off, had been tossed in the hallway to the Collins-Dufflesin
or Eli office, so that was a conversation piece.
Somehow that, I don't recall that bothering me.
I came down here with my wife, my then wife, and two children.
We found a nice apartment uptown that we could rent,
and just a block away from where little is Eli lived at the time.
And it all seemed fine to me.
I didn't have any, I was so excited to be involved in it,
and grateful in a way to be involved in it,
and everybody was approving of what I was doing,
you know, my wife then was, and everybody.
So I didn't have concerns.
I just got right into it, and when I arrived,
there was a volunteer, a regular volunteer,
had been down several times, named Jerry Gutman,
and Jerry at my gutman from New York City,
who filled out a file card for each pending case in the office.
And when I got there, he wanted me to,
I sat down with him and he wanted to go over each file card,
well, the file cards were about four inches thick,
and everyone had a case, and I was the lawyer,
and every single one of those cases has of that day.
So it was, there wasn't a lot of time to be, you know,
be worried about it.
I just got got into it, and it was doing it,
trying to organize it, and some, and I worked alone,
but I honestly did basically the civil rights work
with, I was in association with the lawyers upstairs,
but basically I was supposed to take the lead
and make sure these things happened,
and I did that alone for about four or five months.
You see, I was so much, I felt they shouldn't have this volunteer
lawyer program, and I convinced Henry Schwartz's child
that, see, what they did is they flew the lawyers in,
they paid the airfare, and they paid the hotel bills.
Well, you could hire a lawyer if it was less than that,
and, but the problem was there weren't many lawyers
in Louisiana who wanted to do that,
and, but I found one, a fellow named Don Juno,
who had recently graduated from Tulane,
and he was, he's a very unusual person,
and he's white, he's very unusual person,
and he wanted to do this, so by December,
I came down, full time, late July, by December,
he had joined the office, and so we had two lawyers,
which was great, and I stopped having,
pretty much stopped having the volunteers,
which was kind of a distraction,
and I think by the following summer,
I had three, I had two lawyers with addition to myself,
it got to be three, one point I reached four,
so we really had a law of this going,
and a lot of help and so on.
Let me ask you about the, the complaint filed in 65,
some of the before from there,
did, did, one of the reasons that you like
have an active LDF connection?
You go to the next one, go to the next one.
No, they didn't, they knew all the people and all,
but they were core lawyers,
and there was, there was a core organization,
you know, LDF started as the nonprofit part of the NAACP,
now of course, it's completely different,
but there was a core thing that was called
the scholarship education, defense fund for racial equality.
The call was the Congress of racial equality,
and that was their client,
and that was where the input from New York City
would come in.
There was a man named Carl Racklin,
who was the head of it,
and he would come in and out of town.
You mentioned filing a complaint that day was July 15,
65, just after,
not two weeks after the act is taken.
Tell the seventh's taken effect.
Actually, in those early days,
you mentioned that you could borrow a boilerplate
filing on the school side,
but you know that the problem.
Well, that complaint, you say July 15, 1965,
I was not here yet,
but I thought the complaint,
the charge wasn't complete enough,
and I redid it,
to list the practices more specifically,
that I thought were a problem.
How they did the one in July,
I don't know, I would guess it was a rushed job,
just from the circumstances.
The one I filed,
I had listed a lot of issues
that later became prominent issues,
testing and seniority,
and segregated local unions
and different things that were,
I don't think mentioned in the first charge,
but it was, that,
you had to start over on a blank sheet of paper
for that one,
and unlike the school's segregation with a gation,
which was going on, you know,
for quite some time,
there was this famous new all-in-school desegregation case
many years before,
much more established.
Did you have to rival in early summer 2006?
Did you have an active pattern of communication
with the part of L.D.F that was engaged in early title seven work?
No, I didn't.
I don't think L.D.F,
if they had a title seven case in Louisiana,
I don't know what it was.
I don't think they did.
Did you wouldn't have called up to folks working on these issues
in New York City to say,
hey, what are you guys doing on these L.D.F?
On the title seven front?
No.
I'd love to know some of you to dry out
the part about the loose stuff,
but I don't think they did.
Did you wouldn't have called up to folks working on these issues
in New York City to say,
well, the part about the loose stuff,
some of your impressions about these key three individuals
you mentioned and how and why it was that
for the loose stuff had become such an active place for struggle?
It's the last question first.
It became active because of the three individuals,
and I think if they had been somewhere else,
it would have been active somewhere else.
They had an unbelievable commitment and drive
and perseverance to what they were trying to achieve.
And there were two other factors.
There was the Crown Zellabak Mill,
which employed thousands of, I don't know,
maybe a thousand people.
And it wasn't one of these southern towns.
There were nobody really has a job.
You know, they're making out in various ways,
these are union workers and an union contract,
and they were used to organization.
And the Far as Employment was concerned,
the complaints were quite clear.
And because Crown Zellabak was from San Francisco,
a group in San Francisco took a very active interest
in supporting what they were doing,
including sending money.
Primarily sending money.
What did black workers were attempting to do?
What the Buggalus of Wooders League was trying to do.
And they were pressuring Crown through the San Francisco community
to make changes.
Crown never would make changes until they were forced to,
but they were getting that pressure.
So the fact that there was that input from San Francisco
was important in terms of not that the movement was financed
in any significant way.
But if they wanted to buy placards for signs,
there was a little kitty to do that.
And each of these people got a trip to San Francisco,
which they had never been out of Louisiana.
And it kind of gave them a broad scope about what was going on,
some recognition and a national location.
So I think those things are unusual about Buggalusa.
It's a, I can't really compare it to a lot of other towns.
As far as my observation was, it was kind of the hottest line,
segregationist mall city.
There wasn't much leeway.
And that continues to today, as far as I'm concerned, up there.
Many, many years later in the 1990s, 1990s,
after I was living in Washington, lost touch,
sort of, came back, moved back, reconnected with my friends in Buggalusa.
Gail Jenkins encouraged me to represent some police officers,
black police officers, with their complaints about lesser treatment,
discriminatory treatment they were getting.
And they would have been easy things to correct.
But the mayor would not give one inch on it.
It was just remarkable that 45 years had gone by
and asking for things like posting the opportunities for training.
So it's not just bored of mouth among the white officers.
Didn't want to do that.
Things like that, there were bigger things too,
but they wouldn't do anything.
So Buggalusa has kind of a particular hard line about everything
that I think kind of provoked more activity.
I assume in some other places in Louisiana when the storekeepers
got the kind of pressure they were getting in Buggalusa,
you know, there were things like being able to try on clothes
or not.
Middle things, it seems like little things,
but there was never any give up there.
So I think that had to do it.
All right, now about the people.
When I came back to Louisiana in the 90s,
I spent a lot of time talking with Gail Jenkins.
In fact, I recorded conversations with her.
And not that she was bragging at anything,
but I got the firm impression that she was the spark
that created an organization that could take on the role
of Buggalusa, vote as Lee took on.
The only thing I particularly mentioned
is that she wanted a man to lead it.
And she didn't feel, she felt it would be more effective
if a man led it.
And I think she even mentioned a large man.
I'm not sure of that.
I may be adding that pop, but I know they're the plots, too.
And there was this man, A.C. Young,
who was an outspoken kind of well-known guy in the community.
And she approached him and asked him to do this according to her.
I never discussed this with A.C.
And she wanted to think about it.
And ultimately, he said he would do it.
And when he did it, he jumped in with both feet,
and he did everything he read her.
And her cousin was Bob Hicks.
And she encouraged him to get in, and he did.
He and his wife both, and they all played tremendously significant roles.
Hicks was a more...
Not so flamboyant as A.C. Young,
and could get more into the details of lawsuits.
And he became the plaintiff in a lot of the things we did.
He could testify very well, and not...
And many other attributes.
And their home on Ninth Street,
which they've since named Robert Hicks Avenue, I think,
was the center place for anyone coming to Bogolusa
in connection with Civil Rights.
And it wasn't just lawyers.
It was Civil Rights workers.
There was a call worker in town.
James Farmer came to Bogolusa.
Other men named Lincoln Lynch,
I don't know what that name means any new,
but he was the second in command in Kour.
He came to Bogolusa,
and everything would always happen at the Hicks House,
with food.
And there were these stories that I little bit precede my time,
but about the men on the roof on the Hicks House,
in response to threats that he had received,
because of what he was doing.
And so there was a show of readiness to fight back there.
I'm in on the roof with rifles,
and nobody came.
It's that kind of thing.
And Hicks was up for that,
and he certainly never backed down for a second.
So they all played somewhat different roles.
When there was time to give a speech,
or to Big Rally,
he easy young would give it.
He was a frontman in the marching line,
and a lot of people had tremendous amount of respect
in the community.
And Hicks was right next to him,
but a little bit more subdued about things,
a little bit more into the schedule,
into what date something's going to happen,
that kind of thing.
So I'm making myself clear.
And you couldn't have one without the other,
and it was a wonderful combination.
They didn't fight.
No competition.
AZ was the president.
And Bob was the vice president,
and Gail was the secretary,
and never changed.
And I was very nice.
Someone else who came to Bogolusa
were the Freedom Singers,
and the Freedom Theater.
Was that what it was called?
The Free Southern Theater came to Bogolusa.
It took the Union Hall,
where they had their meetings.
They had a performance.
The Freedom Singers came.
So it was attracting that kind of potential.
So I was a little bit more worried about it.
I was a little worried about it.
We're back.
So I want to ask about,
after round 166,
you pursued the Crown Zellbot case, obviously,
and pushed forward,
and would come trial in the summer 67, I think.
Correct.
Which could grow in Canada.
Right.
Would that try to work in some sense?
Can you talk about that process of pushing a Title VII case forward,
moving it towards trial in that moment?
There's not a lot of...
There aren't cases that the field was selling you to the law.
Yeah.
By that summer 67,
we had filed additional cases involving other plants in Bogolusa,
and they came to trial,
was consolidated with a government case,
United States versus local one.
Well, when I was practicing law in Washington,
I was doing a lot of antitrust cases.
And I became familiar,
very familiar with discovery, depositions,
production of documents,
which the lawyers who hadn't had that experience
didn't really have any familiarity with and weren't doing.
And I got into a more methodical mode of filing the interrogatories,
filing the request for production of documents,
filing motions to compel the scarry when the responses were not forthcoming,
scheduling depositions before the hearing and taking them.
And it would be more of a...
One reason is I had the money to do that
because LCDC was paying for deposition transcripts
and all that kind of thing.
But I had the distinct impression that
earlier they'd be more of a Russian to try to get into court a week afterwards
and not have all the homework done.
That was one thing that I organized, the material,
and of course George was a tremendous help.
We kind of split the issues.
And he did a tremendous amount of research about testing
and the impact of testing on fair employment.
And that was a new issue at that time.
People really hadn't been talking about that.
And he got a lot of experts to help him,
people and not lawyers, but people in the testing field.
So that was one major advantage.
Another was there was a new judge just appointed named Frederick Hebey,
who had nothing in his background would suggest he'd be sympathetic
to these kind of cases, but he was sympathetic to these kind of cases.
And I, a lot of the cases, a lot of the litigation in Bogolusa,
went before Judge Hebey.
Not because of any special tricks, it just fell that way.
He had the school case.
He had both, he had all three employment discrimination cases.
Other cases.
The school cases in Bogolusa, see,
they went further than any other school cases because they wanted to litigate
about who would be the prom queen and how the football players
are being treated.
And every last thing, the people in Bogolusa would not accept
what they call the law, one vestige of discrimination.
I mean, they wanted to get everything out on the table.
And Judge Hebey would call a hearing.
I remember we had a two-day hearing on a Friday and Saturday
about the selection of the prom queen.
And he treated as as serious as any other case he could have had.
And it was very wonderful, really.
Because another judge could just throw you out, or not schedule it.
I mean, you don't get to trial because you want to get to trial.
You get to trial because the judge says, okay, here's the trial date.
And so we've got a lot of cooperation from this man.
See, the courts were so different that not only from Hebey
and he's not the only district judge that helped us out a lot.
But the Court of Appeals was just perfect in terms of what we wanted to do there.
These men who really cared about these things
and would give you, like I mentioned before,
about the school case in St. Francisville,
they'd give you what you were entitled to overnight.
And so all those things coalesced, I didn't have to do that
when it's in the Hebey cases, but in other cases, I certainly did.
So I attributed more to those factors than anything else.
Some of the issues in the Crown's Eliva case were perfectly obvious.
The seniority issues and the testing issues were not.
And I mentioned George developed one, and I worked on the other.
And I got help from, it was a case in Virginia,
corals against Philip Morris, that was a precedent.
And I think the first case really, was that later?
Well, then it wasn't a precedent.
I thought there was a precedent in that case.
Maybe it came later as a precedent in some of our...
Okay, so...
Judge Fosson.
And yeah, and a woman in Gabrielle McDonald later became a federal judge in Texas
was a lawyer for the plaintiffs.
In addition, I began, you mentioned whether I was consulting with the lawyer's defense,
legal defense fund, which I wasn't, but I did become in contact with the lawyers
from the Civil Rights Division of the Palm Nurgustus.
And they were doing a lot of thinking about these seniority issues.
And really showed me some things I hadn't realized myself about them.
One guy particularly, Robert Moore and David Rose.
And we tried the look 29 case together.
But even before that, the case case was tried first,
I was getting kind of different vantage points on how this seniority system
can adversely affect black employees who had never been allowed into white jobs.
Need I say, before the Civil Rights Act will pass, there were black jobs and white jobs.
There was no two ways of better, no fooling, no...
And two unions, and each union had its own jobs in their contract.
And a question is how you put that together, and it's complicated.
And anyway, by the time we went to trial, I had it straight, and Judge Hebey boarded
an issued a preliminary judgment.
He did his issue as a written opinion until three years later,
but he issued an injunction at the end of the trial.
And so I guess that's the answer to your question.
Let me take you back at the bubble list and talk with me.
You're grappling up there with...
And the mostly is grappling with the most basic things, education, jobs.
Can you talk a bit more about the...
Some illustrious tale about the nature of the...
Kind of for our record here, what she saw in the schools, what she saw at Crown Zellerbach.
A little bit more of the fabric of that experience for those folks at the time.
When we used to say a desegregation of what had been issued in the Southern School desegregation cases,
it was the most token.
The result was as token as it could possibly be.
It was what we've called then freedom of choice.
And every white student chose a white school,
and two or three or four black kids pushed by their parents,
basically would go to the white school, and all the other black children
would go to the same school they were going to.
So I had occasion to visit even after there was a desegregation order in Bogolusa, the schools.
And they were blatantly run down.
I mean, they didn't look anything like the white schools looked.
And I interviewed teachers, and I heard about how they would pay less,
and didn't get the supplies they needed.
And you could just walk by the school and see what the building looked like,
and what they were dilapidated.
And that motivated our office to really press that particular issue,
which is one of the things I spent a lot of time working on,
which was eliminating freedom of choice and reestablishing the school districts
in some kind of non-racial way that everybody goes to the school in the other house.
And the first place that was ordered, I think, in the south, was in Washington Parish by Judge Hebe.
I got the citation of the case and that material I gave you.
And then later on, we achieved similar relief in the Supreme Court of the United States
on a south wall, on a whole regional basis that had to happen right away.
It couldn't be, there was no more deliberate speed.
Those were very important issues, because the status of school desegregation,
as I found it when I got to the south, I'm not saying about the big cities that I never was in,
a big city case like New Orleans, but in these small towns, it amounted just little next to nothing.
And of course, the children who had to do this, I'm just reading Shullian Hunter's book
about her going to the University of Georgia.
And the children that had to do this had to put up with quite a bit.
It wasn't just going to school anymore, these eight and nine-year-olds being these heroes,
and that's not fair. And anyway, so that was a school situation.
By the time I left my job at LCDC, there still was no significant integration of the school.
Some bogeyless happened to fall in here.
With respect to the paper mill, of course, I got familiar with the man I became the lawyer for the black union.
I was able to tour the plant and see the jobs.
And of course, a lot of the defenses about these seniority issues was that the black employees were incompetent to do,
hadn't been trained. They wanted everybody to go up step by step and get at the back of the line, essentially,
and learn, but some of these men were 50 and 55 years old.
They didn't have any time to get at the back of the line.
And I began to observe the jobs, and they were with very few exceptions, quite simple jobs.
And I could see by just watching them what the men were doing.
I was in there by court order to view the plants that anything complicated, like fixing a broken machine,
they'd call it a craftsman who was specializing in that machine.
But in terms of a working machine, the production of corrugated board is a very simple process.
It's a repetitive process. And it might take, and I've always been cynical about the amount of training you need for things.
I would say in two or three days maximum, any reasonably intelligent person could have done any of those jobs.
They wanted them to wait 25 years.
So I saw what it was on the ground, and that, of course, encouraged me, because I didn't know anything about making paper.
I hadn't gotten encouraged me to, in my legal pursuits, by seeing what was actually involved in these jobs.
And, of course, the pay scales were dramatically different.
The highest paying black job under the pre-Title 7 Union contract was picking the final product off the assembly line and putting it on pallets.
And that was the highest paying job. They were sweeping the floor job. They were lesser jobs.
And the white job started a notch above that job, and would go up six or seven steps to what was really good blue collar pay at that time.
So, and that got into, it kind of slid into a sex discrimination issue, because they wouldn't, they had two bags.
There was a box plant, two bag plants, making two different types of paper bags, and a paper mill, which takes wood, and turns it into paper.
The bag plants were all white, and no, I'm trying to get, there were no women in the box planted.
It was an aspect of sex discrimination about the bag plants. It slips my mind right now, but they had us, I know what it was.
They didn't employ women at all, regardless of race, in the box plant and the paper mill, but they employed them in the bag plant.
And the bag plant, they were no black employees at all. The bag plants, plural.
And so it kind of became a combination of sex and race. And I noticed that touring the plant, that there were no black employees.
And they had a separate black union for the box plant and a separate one for the paper mill, but no black union, of course, for the other ones, because there were no black employees.
So a lot of being able to get in there and be on the scene. And as I said before about Bougalus, I had clients in upstate New York and into Lula, Louisiana, which is as high as you can go, and still be in Louisiana.
I had clients in Monroe, and what's that pretty town where Stanley lives to the west of here?
But I didn't get over there. There had to be an event for me to go that far. But Bougalus, I was there all the time.
So it was very, you get a deeper understanding of what's going on.
Did you pick a golden back in the day or kind of know what you had?
Oh, sure. I would, I never slept in Bougalus. I made a rule of thumb not to sleep in those places.
Because I guess that was my fear of violence. That I just didn't want to be asleep in one of the motels in these towns.
I would go to Faraday, Louisiana, which was another civil rights hotspot, and I'd cross the bridge in the Mississippi and stay in matches.
And when I went to Toulula, I would cross the bridge and stay in Vicksburg, because I just always had a feeling it wouldn't be a good idea to be sleeping alone in one of these motels.
So I never stayed in Bougalus. There was no reason to actually. It was, it was about 90 minutes.
But they would, at least in the early stages, they would drive me to the border of Washington, Parish, to see me out.
And I never knew whether that was, I never really, I don't know what that was necessary, not necessary.
In fact, there's never any problem. And it may be because they were driving me. But I always came home.
I'm a theme of risk of violence and all of that.
Bougalus, obviously, has a pretty active chapter of the Deacon's for the fence.
You're saying now they do? No, but I think they do.
And I'm wondering your perspective on the implications of the Deacons in the community and say in relation to the civil rights activities of the voters league.
Well, okay. I have a rather unorthodox view about the Deacons and the fence.
In the time I was living here and working on problems in Bougalusa, I never heard about the Deacons and the fence.
I never maybe overstates it. Maybe I heard about it. But there was certainly no members to meet the sort of guy from the Deacons and everything was under the Bougalusa voters league.
I did know about how when there was some threats of violence against the Hicks household, friends of theirs came and climbed on the roof and spent the night with rifles.
Now that gets to be a Deacons and defense story. At the time, I think it was friends of the Hicks coming over there with their rifles.
So I just don't, I think there's something about the Deacons story is very attractive to historians.
I'm not saying that. Because I hear so much about it now and I heard nothing about it.
And I've spoken with Louis Eli about this extensively and he agrees with me.
So I don't know. Not really what I have to say about it.
I did, like I say, when I left town, not for long, but in the early days, 65 and maybe the first few must 65.
Somebody would want to follow me down in a car down to the border.
But the word Deacon was never mentioned and I didn't even think I saw any guns. I didn't see any guns.
I never saw any guns actually. I get right down to it.
So I read these stories about people had their trunk full of rifles. I just don't know what this is all about.
Maybe I was just naive, but that's my honest thing I can tell you. That's my impression.
Do you have any sense of the claim?
Yes.
I think there was some clan violence against some of the mortgages.
I'm a little indistinct about it in my mind, but I think there was.
And I don't know who could tell you now exactly who was there because the main people are in a round right now.
But I don't think it was massive in any way. I mean, there was bad. I think there was one or two occasions where a shot was fired during a march and somebody was hurt.
I'm just not that clear. It didn't happen when I was around.
The Bougalus movement was way underway long before I got here.
And some of the most important things that were going to happen had already happened. Hicks against night. You're familiar with that case.
I had nothing to do with whatsoever. It was concluded the day before I arrived as a volunteer.
But it had been Robert Hicks and several others taking on the chief of police because of lack of protection of marches, which certainly means to me there must have been some harassing of marches.
So I'm not a good source for this because as I say, Judge Christian Berry, a very powerful man, put an injunction in against every police officer in town.
I didn't see that kind of activity. I just didn't see it. So I don't really want to talk to them after about it because I don't know much about it really. But that's just my impression of it.
But I do think there was violence. And when we marched to Baton Rouge, which was entering new territory, the word was out that the headquarters of the Cluj Cux clan is in Livingston Parish.
And there was a lot of discussion and I was engaged in negotiations with state offices about where they're going to let them march through Livingston Parish. Although it's right on the way to Baton Rouge, but I suppose some other route could have been found.
But because they felt there was going to be really violent, serious violence in Livingston Parish. And I don't know if you've ever seen the picture of the march going through Livingston Parish, but there were troopers lined up on each side of the marchers, which forming a barrier between the marches and the observers.
And when it came, push came to shove with, and the godsmen who were there, I guess that's what they were, national godsmen, way outnumbered the marchers. So they were really being protected. And the only thing I actually saw was some soda bottles being, from glass soda bottles being thrown above the police to the land in the area where the marches were.
But they had cleared the area of anybody that was going to had a gun or anything like that. So that was kind of a scary thing. But it didn't come to fruition in any serious way.
But we were thinking that the clan was in Livingston Parish. Although undoubtedly there were people.
You know, organizations like the clan and the deacons that kind of murky, it's not like belonging to the ACLU. It's an attitude more than anything else. And it certainly had the attitude in Bogolusa, but I just didn't see much of it.
I'm going to say that on the call.
I'm going to plug back in.
You are.
Okay.
We're back after just a brief break. Some of that I'd like to take you back to turn again to the Picspecrancel about trial before Judge Hebe and summer 67.
Any sets and things about the judge, very interesting perspective.
He emerged in the end as someone who you were happy to be in front of.
Yes, definitely.
What's about the trial, special recollections or impressions, memories that persist?
There were two issues that were really being litigated, the seniority issue and the testing issue.
And George showed, and they each side had witnesses.
And George Cooper showed up at the trial with a trunk.
I'm talking about the kind of trunk a kid would take to camp.
A big trunk full of books that he had found that either the witnesses for the Fr. Trounds,
Ella Beck had said the opposite things with what they were saying now or other experts demolishing what they were saying.
And he walked in the court, he opened the trunk, and he piled all these books on the council table.
It was like a library. It was all all-road books.
And each witness for crown, I'm telling you the highlights in my mind, George would start in with Fr. Trounds book.
And he'd go through every book with them.
And he just made them look like completed heets.
And what seemed like a tough road to hoax is the test had nothing about race in it, you know how these tests are.
By this process, he really made it clear to the judge who was open to having it made clear to him what the impact of these tests were and how useless they were for the purpose they were intended, which is to find good employees.
We had our witnesses too on that issue which George had found and brought to New Orleans and testified and the crown had theirs.
But it was the cross examination that sticks out in my mind.
And on the testing issue was on this seniority issue was a little less dramatic, but we did have charts and we had made charts to display in a way the judge could see it from the bench.
What would be the impact of the existing seniority system versus one that did not incorporate the past and went on for quite a while.
The child did, I would guess it was something like eight days of trial.
And with a lot of attendance from the people in Bogolusa, particularly of the crown's yellow back workers, Bob Hicks was sitting next to me the entire eight days.
That's what I meant by. That's the kind of thing he could do. He'd keep the record straight. He'd help me with doing it.
And the judge, I think, was impressed by that. I think he was, this man was changed. The judge was changed by his exposure to these civil rights cases.
And I think one of them was the, there's a lot of feeling sometimes by a judge that the lawyers are ginning up the cases, are making up the theories and there really is no client. It's just a name.
But by virtue of having 30 people from crown's yellow back in the courtroom completely, you know, got rid of any of that flavor and it really became what it was, which was a community that was committed to this.
And that was not just in that case, but a lot of other cases before Judge Hebeal. I said he had the school case and a lot of kids came down to be there for it.
That was another thing about the movement in Buggles. They responded to that kind of situation. They would do that. That's really what my thoughts are about the case.
Honestly, I'm going to send you into the record that sometimes we pass right over for our purpose today. Could you just recap and brief terms the introduction of things like the Wonderlick test and how they were employed and why it became something that had to be fought against?
The Wonderlick test is a short answer test, maybe 20 questions, 30 questions at most, which tested very simple forms of knowledge, including definitions of words, knowledge of geography,
and spatial relation things. And it had been used, it was a device that had been used for years around the country as some kind of minimal intelligence to get a job thing when there was no issues about race just involved.
The Wonderlick test was done by the WIthesack test until the Civil Rights Act passed. So none of these white workers and these supposedly difficult jobs had ever passed the test.
They made it a requirement for employment. White or black had passed the test.
The statistics showed, well, I showed two things. One is that historically and in Bogolusa, the white pass rate was much higher than the black pass rate. Three things had shown.
Secondly, that there was a concept of job relatedness came into being at that time. That it would be legal if it was job related.
So if you tested an electrician on how do you set up a 220 volt socket, that would be a job related test.
But that all evidence that could be obtained found that there was no job relatedness to this test.
That you could not predict from the test how anybody would perform on the job in a paper mill.
That's become common wisdom now. The EEOC ultimately issued guidelines on the issue and the office of contract compliance, the Department of Labor issued guidelines.
Now employees are very sensitive about, very careful about using tests. But the result of them was that eight out of ten black employees were disqualified on the first half hour they were in the employment office.
And not so for whites. And the culture and then the science leads into cultural factors. One of the classic questions on the test, which I'll just use as an example, because it's such a good one, is what is RSVP me?
Well, it turned out these black kids didn't know about RSVP. And that's a kind of symbolic question. But not isolated in its context, in its meaning.
And that was something that was just bound to fall. And I did a lot of litigation in other cases in Washington, D.C., and elsewhere about these test things.
Because there were different quirks that would come up. But the one-delict test was like a sitting duck because it had nothing to do with the work involved.
Let me also ask you on the seniority side, you were due to briefly a few minutes ago to a very complicated question that you worked very, very hard to argue your way through. And that's the question of how does the law of grapple with the LAKIS CFX pre-act segregation, and so far as it reaches the seniority question?
You want me to explain it about the problem?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll give you two examples. When Crowns Ella back merged the progression lines, which they did it voluntarily, you might say. They weren't a pressure from the EOC, but they did it early on.
They couldn't maintain jobs with racial labels on them after the Civil Rights Act. They merged them by pay so that the white line may have been $3 an hour, $3.50, $4.55, and the black line would be $1.75, $2.50, $2.75.
So they are making up those numbers, and they put them together. So at the result of putting them together based on their wage discrimination, they had all the black jobs at the bottom and the white jobs at the top, and they had a system of job seniority.
It didn't matter how long you worked in the plant. The only thing that mattered was how long you worked in the next line down in the line of progression when there was a vacancy.
So if there was a vacancy in the very top job, they'd look into the second top job, and they'd see who was in that second top job the longest.
Well, you can see the ramifications of that.
The only job any black man could enter was the lowest rating white job, and then he'd be the junior guy in that job, and they may have been 15 people in that job, and it would take 15 different promotions before he would be able to move into the next job.
So the most basic thing we wanted and presented was that the seniority, the positions should be filled based on plant seniority.
How long you worked for Crown Zellaback, so that when a job opened, and there were more than one people would sign a bid sheet to bid on the job, that the senior employee on a plant-wide basis would be given first consideration, and if he was qualified to do the job,
he would get it. So that was very simple, and of course the defense had to do with qualifications, and how many years it would take to learn how to mix the glue, you know.
So all these orders had reservations in them about qualifications, but they were carefully restricted to qualifications thing.
And then came the notion of having to go through every job on the way to the top, which had always been the system, and they were all good, it's a non-racial system, we've always done this, you move from job 5 to 4 to 3, so that although a black employee on based on plants and yourity could go into the lowest ranking white job,
he couldn't go into any other job without for serving in the lowest ranking job, and this is where the lawyers from the department of justice were really inspiring to me, I must say, that they should be allowed to go into any job that becomes open, as long as they can do the job.
And so it wasn't just moving from jobs and yourity to plants and yourity, it was essentially eliminating the line of progression.
That's a thumbnail of the basic points, and it would have different tricks and turns because the lines would sometimes go in two different directions halfway up, and you have to account for that somewhere other, but those were the two things, getting rid of plants and yourity and getting rid of the lines of progression.
And they fought light hell about it, and the unions did as well initially, they turned around, but all it initially they did as well, because there was something sacred in the contract, the fact defenses were raised early on in Title VII, that if it's in the collective bottom agreement it can't be illegal.
And so that was another hurdle you had to overcome, the contract was illegal itself, and so those were the kinds of issues that were involved.
You and your civil road would become an absolutely critical piece in our Law Review, published 69 on these questions, and would have so much influence on how courts grapple with these things, including through Creeps and et cetera.
And I'm very interested in your perspective on both how you labor to construct that piece.
And the challenges you found in front of you in crafting the arguments that had been once you've been working on, obviously, in the fact of litigation, and your sense of the impact of that piece.
I want to go back and give you my second example on the preceding question, because it's going to feed into what you're saying.
Another situation was where no blacks were hired at all, and that was true in the New Orleans transit system.
Every bus driver, every trolley driver in town was white.
And when the Civil Rights Act passed, they began to hire black employees, and they had a system of company whites and yority.
The one we were fighting for in Buggles, they already had it, but the black employees didn't have it.
And as a result, they would get all the Saturday night shifts and overtime and late at night, and not the good jobs.
And we had a case against New Orleans Public Service, the Fagan against Nopsy, in which also before Judge Hevy, in which he required the assignment of the law.
He required the assignment of job assignments by random, by lottery.
That was a completely different remedy, because they all could drive the bus.
It's just a question at which bus, what time of day you're driving the bus.
So it had to do with the situation where the vestige of past discrimination is not a segregated system like in Bougalooza, but no black employees at all.
And what happens when you get in?
Okay.
The article.
This theory, I don't want to get too technical on you, but there's a provision in Title VII that protects non-discriminatory seniority systems.
And the people defending the status quo would always say, has to be non-discriminatory.
It was created before. There was any black competition for these jobs.
Our position was it was discriminatory because of the impact it had on the black employees.
And the position that we argued soon became widely accepted in the intermediate federal courts.
And the article that we wrote, I think, contributed to that.
Although I must say it was well underway by 1916, but I think it contributed to that.
The way we wrote it was a little more scholarly than the briefs, so the arguments had caught, but essentially was along the same lines.
George and I were all friends. It wasn't like we were strangers, came together for this.
We had tried hicks together. But before that, we were friends in Washington when I was working.
He was a Covenant Burling, and I was an Arnold Porter, and we were lived in the same neighborhood and we were friends.
And he came down here because I asked him to, and that kind of thing.
So it was a very more than collegial. We're all friends writing this thing.
And I wrote half. He wrote half. He edited my half. I edited his half.
And we sent it to the Harvard Law Review. They edited the whole thing. They rearranged it completely.
They put the end at the beginning. And it's how I published.
But it came out at a key time, and it was in the Harvard Law Review, and a lot of people read it.
George once told me that he had gotten a notification from some group that it was the most cited Law Review article in many years.
But Supreme Court had yet to be heard from. And to make a long story short, when it got to Supreme Court, they ruled with what the employer's position on this.
That the system was not discriminatory. If it wasn't adopted with a purpose of injuring or just hampering black minority employment,
in a case involving, I think, the United States versus Teamsters in 1976, maybe 75.
So we had a good run because from 1967 until 1965 or 66,
I'm sorry, 1967 until 1975 or 76, everybody was doing what we were advocating, including the Department of Labor and the contract compliance field.
Are you familiar with that? So it was almost, the job was almost done.
Supreme Court comes along and says, no, it should never happen.
So that was a big kind of intellectual disappointment, but I do feel the job had been done in that instance.
And I did feel that we contributed to that. One thing I want to say about it is when I went to Washington,
see I worked in Michigan for one semester, I didn't want to stay as a professor, came to Washington and got back into civil rights through the Civil Rights, from the Washington Research Project.
But then I went into private practice and what I was getting into finding ways to make money was representing unions.
And one thing we developed was the right of a union to bring a title seven case.
And I was working for unions and doing that, I'm scripting away ahead now.
But the people who were the power, the power that be people in the Washington Union establishment still held it against me because of that article.
And they were very resentful at first. And I had a lot of headwind about that in terms of becoming a lawyer for unions because I had done this kind of traitorous thing.
That was the major personal manifestation that came out of it. And some people still feel that way about it.
The point they were making is if you're being a lawyer, you should be a lawyer, you're going to be a scholarly, you should be a scholar, you shouldn't mix them because it pollutes the objectivity of the scholarly endeavor.
And the truth is I wrote that article the same way I handled Civil Rights case. I wrote that article to advance Civil Rights. I wasn't really trying to be a scholar, although it reads that way.
And so there was something, I guess, some merit in what they were saying. But that was an outgrowth for me, the guy who was the chief guy at the AFL-CIO for example, didn't want to hear about me.
So...
Can we pause again here just for a second?
I...
Okay.
Continue to mention the importance of these judges in influencing these cases. And it seems to be that that was the case throughout the South as well.
Throughout the country.
Listen, this week, five Justice Supreme Court think it's cruel and unusual punishment to keep these prisoners in California, cooked up in these little boots, and four think it's not.
Well, that just tells you the whole story. It's all how the judge feels. It's all law falls away when you get down to those kind of decisions. It's just how who's the person?
And that happens every day all over the country constantly. And it happened here when...
And it's happening now. You can't do a thing in Civil Rights and the courts in New Orleans, the federal courts right now. Every judge on that district court and the court of appeals, they're all bad.
You're thinking of...
Oh, I don't care at all.
Anyway, maybe I'm wrong about every judge, but certainly you can't do the kind of things we were doing. Then they had open arms for us.
I went to Judges' Houses on weekends. They welcomed you in. I spent July 4th, 1967 in Judge Kristen Berry's home in the French Quarter.
And he was on the phone telling the people in Bogalusia. He didn't let those people out of jail in 20 minutes. He was going to have the US Marshal's Force up there and arrest them.
Yeah, it was all that. And through a lot of times I felt I was just kind of setting the table so these guys could do what they felt they should do.
And if you got the wrong thing like the guy in Baton Rouge, it was nothing you could tell them. You could cite cases all day long. They wouldn't care.
I mean, I feel that very strongly. That's one of the reasons why I'm not that interested in law anymore.
Because it's so obvious to me that what we're doing is just a little bit... It's kind of pill political, you might say.
The title of seven cases that Richard Handle lasted for years. Mills Douglas started a case about the Kaiser aluminum plant.
By the time that case was finished and it gone up through the acrylic quartz and through the Supreme Court.
In fact, it was... Relief was handed down, which given out 17 years after they began.
That's another problem. One of those cases lasted so long the plant closed down.
But they still had to pay out millions of dollars for what they had done.
Okay, let me turn your remember back to the very unusual episode in 1967 when I end up in jail and it involves Leander Perez.
And I'm sure that that's enough to cue you for a very interesting story.
Well, in the early 1967 January of February, Gary Duncan and I'm in him, Gary Duncan and his mother... Gary was 19 years old at the time. His mother came to my office.
They had been sent there by the Civil Rights Division of the Department of Justice, which had an office in New Orleans. They had gone there for help.
And they couldn't handle criminal cases, defend criminal cases, and they sent them to me.
And what happened was this young man had a little bit background. Leander Perez fought like no one ever had before had fought against desegregating the public schools and the parish.
Leander Perez was a well-known racist figure who espoused theories of interposition and secession and barring the schoolhouse door and he appeared before Congress and he said these things.
He said at one point, if any civil rights activist ever comes to a document's parish, we have a special place for him on Prince Philip Island with the allocators.
But no one had ever come down and no one had ever done that. In fact, the government brought the school desegregation case and the reason is that it was the only place in Louisiana that nobody would be the plaintiff would stand up and be the plaintiff because of the intimidation that this man had created.
His son was a district attorney and he appointed the judges. He was the head of the parish council, which is the governing body down there.
The older man was appointed the judges. So, Judge Kristen Berry heard the case, put an injunction and effect requiring certain desegregation.
By that time, it was so things had passed to the point that he actually entered an order that achieved some desegregation on a more than token basis in Plakamins parish.
And there's a lot of furor down there about this. And Duncan was driving his truck down the only highway there is on the west side of the Mississippi River in Plakamins parish and he came to the school and he saw that his two of his nephews were being encountered by four white boys on the side of the road.
He could see a fight was developing. He got out of the truck. He asked that was going on and one of his cousins said they're giving us a problem and he said, well, get in the truck.
And at this point, he's a very sweet guy, Duncan. He touched one of the boys on the elbow and said, go ahead on.
Well, the father of one of the boys was within eyesight of this and he reported that Duncan had slapped his son.
And that night, Duncan was arrested and charged with battery, criminal charge punishable by two years in jail.
And God bless him. He wasn't going to accept that. And he, like I say, he and his mother went to the Department of Justice. They sent him to me.
I agreed to represent him with Collins Douglass in Eli. We all agreed to represent him. And we began to represent him.
And we represented, we didn't just raise civil rights issues in cases. When we were representing somebody, we represent, like any lawyer, raise every issue possibly could to help your client.
One of them was the Louisiana jury system at the time, which did not allow for juries in any case, unless the punishment was more than two years.
So he was going to be tried before this judge that Perez had appointed. So I filed a motion to challenge that system, whatever the motion was exactly called, but to question the constitutionality of the lack of jury trial was denied.
We tried the case. I had my witnesses. They had their witnesses. The judge ruled for the, for the state and sentenced, not into prison, actually 60 days in prison and a fine.
And I was intent on appealing, particularly on the jury issue, because the law on the Supreme Court was developing that more and more of the provisions of the Bill of Rights were going to be applicable and stay criminal proceedings.
In fact, I mentioned before, a courtist had just won that for counsel, right to counsel. So I went to the Supreme Court of Louisiana. So I needed to go to the Supreme Court of Louisiana to exhaust my remedies and then apply rits to the Supreme Court.
And I went down after the, so I did that. I got, I kept them at a jail until the Supreme Court of Louisiana acted on it.
They issued a one sentence order saying no violation, then they recited what the statute said. And I went down again to get a state of execution of the sentence until I filed the petition of Supreme Court.
And I went to the judge's office. I called the headmaid and appointed. I knew I was coming. I went down there. He signed the state. He kept on going out of jail until, and as I walked out, Leander Perez and a sheriff standing there in the hall arrested me.
And the charge was practicing law without a license, which in fact, I didn't have a Louisiana license. I was a lawyer temporarily in the state, reacting with local counsel. That's my legal position.
So they put me in jail. And I got one phone call and I made it to my colleagues in New Orleans and Don Juno came down and bailed me out before the afternoon was out.
And I was in the jail with the white prisoners, and holding with the white prisoners. And some guys started telling me the story about another LCD lawyer. I knew it was an LCD story in Alabama, who had been arrested for the same reason.
And they said, can you imagine anyone representing me? They got it. So, and I'm saying, oh, really? Really? Is that right?
But Juno got me out. And we are consulted with my other people involved with my situation down there. And we filed a case to join my prosecution and to declare the any prohibition on the activities of outside civil rights lawyers, unconstitutional as a violated, not only the lawyers rights, but the individuals rights to counsel.
And that became a, I got blown up. So the case was assigned to Judge Casabrey because of a constitutionality of a state law involved. A three-judge court was assembled, which included Judge Hebe, my friend. And Judge Ainsworth, a member of the Court of Appeals.
And there was discovery, and then there was a trial in the trial lasted for three weeks. And every day there was a story in the Times per Kiyun about what was going on in the courtroom.
And essentially, it took just a few minutes of an hour, so to describe what I just said to you, what the facts were. It all turned out to, like, a congressional committee hearing on the state of law practice in Louisiana.
And lawyers were coming in from all over the state, both brought in, or the government intervened on our side. It was me and Duncan with the plaintiffs and the head of court, Isaac Reynolds at that time, with the plaintiffs.
And then the government became a plaintiff intervener, and this defendant was Perez and the state of Louisiana intervened on the side of the Perez.
And the State Bar Association intervened on the side of Perez. So there were five parties. And a small part of the testimony had to do with me and Duncan and what happened in Louisiana.
90% had to do with how does a black person get a lawyer in this state if he wants to break certain rights under federal law? And it was very interesting to watch.
And in due course, the federal court avoided the constitutional question, which is what courts are supposed to do. And they see there were two defenses. One is the constitution was to protect protecting what I was doing.
Another is that Louisiana statute says an out of state lawyer can practice in cooperation with local counsel if he's temporarily in the state.
So I was in my second year of residence here. But the fact is I was on leave from Audel and Porter. I had an arrangement with them. I could go back. And that was official that I was on leave.
I was supposed to go stay here for one year. That was my first leave of absence was for one year. At the end of the first year, I had already been arrested. And the trial was coming up. It just didn't seem right to be leaving. Plus I was in the middle of the things that I didn't want to leave.
And they gave me another year's leave of absence. So that was very helpful. And we tried it. And they were trying to prove I was a resident by the fact that I had utility bills. And I'm trying to prove I'm not. Because I still have a DC driver's license.
That was going on. That was one part. And the other part was about the state of law in Louisiana. And they issued an opinion ruling on the part that I was temporarily in the state.
And they said that I am temporary in the state. And I was leaving in August like he's like a testify. And that I was operating with local counsel. It was, I certainly was.
Their names was on everything. And Bob Collins was there the first day. And I went down alone after the first day. But Bob Collins was there the first day. And there was a problem about federal courts issuing injunctions against state criminal proceedings, which is embodied in a federal statute. But that is an exception when the federal government is asking for the injunction.
So the government intervening in my behalf proved to be very helpful as well. Because when in the opinion they explained how they could issue this injunction by pointing out the government had asked for it.
And so then I all that during this period I filed the application of the Supreme Court for Ritz. It was granted.
The argument was scheduled Gary Duncan and I and several others went up to Washington and I argue the case. And decision came down ruling that it's illegal to file a violates the 14th amendment not to allow juries and state trials except for the most minor crimes.
And not including what he was charged with. And so when it got back they decided to they tried Duncan again and they have a jury.
And we brought a case saying the only reason you could possibly try the mad at this point after all this was just intimidation and vengeance. And we filed a case called Duncan versus Perez.
And it went before Judge Cassidy and he ruled in our favor and he should have nice opinions saying that it was it couldn't inculc- unbelievable any other reason would could underlie the reason this was a malicious prosecution.
And they enjoy them from prosecuting the reproduci-duck and so it was kind of a trifect I guess in that sense. And that's the story of that case.
And he asked about-
And he grew and turned out to be an important leader in the parish on all kinds of other issues. He became the head of a he became a stripper and he was the head of the stripper's association and represented he became an important figure after that.
And he's still my friend. He was and he moved out of the parish after the hurricane but he still lives right.
And he asked about some of the other work that you didn't in Louisiana.
I think there's some very interesting voting rights litigation that you pursued up in Madison, Paris.
Were you one couple of rather exceptional individuals?
After the Voting Rights Act was passed in these largely black parishes in upstate Louisiana there was a lot of voter registration.
You probably know this but the act bypassed all the unpleasantness and hurdles of going down to the white registrar who hated you and they would appoint federal registrars and made it nice and simple to get the registration done.
So the voting population became very substantially African-American.
And the first instance in which we brought a case was that there was a man named Zoma White who was the head of the Madison parish voters league who was running for police chief against the white police chief in town.
And he lost the election when Frisk was came by by about 10-15 votes.
And we investigated and later found out that the clerk of court had gone to the white old age homes in the parish of which they were numerous.
And got all these white people to vote for the gay brought them ballots to their bedside and got them to and goes without saying didn't go to any black old age homes.
And he had collected something like 200 ballots that way.
And we filed suit of the Voting Rights Act.
He was heard by a judge named Dawkins in Monroe.
I believe the government intervened on our side in that case, the federal government, but maybe it was the next case.
I don't really remember. No way second now. That was the second one.
Trying to get this straight. One of them they did. One of them they didn't, I think.
Anyway, the judge didn't want to cast any aspersions on the public officials.
So he adopted a novel doctrine called discrimination in fact.
He said they didn't mean anything bad, but in fact it was discriminatory.
And he set aside the election and the election was held.
White swung the election was police chief for many years.
Did you advance that doctrine in your claim?
The fact that he made that up. No, I didn't advance that doctrine.
I went to the homes, white homes with these ballots. I know I can possibly say that, but I didn't care.
And then the only way I ever knew who did that doctrine again was the same judge in the next case.
The next case was a vacancy in the...
Let me get this straight. Which position it was.
I think it was a school board position.
There was a vacancy and there had a fill in unexpired term.
Now in Louisiana, there's a lever you can pull, at least there was then, to vote for everybody on the party line.
And the symbol of the Democrats at that point was the rooster.
And you could pull this tab in the voting booth and you'd be voting for everybody who's running as a rooster.
And so there was a black candidate, a man named Harrison Brown, who was running for the school board.
He was a teacher in the school system.
And they disconnected that position from the line.
So if you pulled that lever, you voted for everybody except Harrison Brown, who's on the line.
And as a result, most people, most of the supporters didn't know that.
I don't know how that worked for the White candidate, but it didn't adversely affect the White candidate for some reason or other.
I mean, I do it the way the ballot was set up.
So all his supporters went down. All the voters, league members, went down to vote for him.
And they think they're voting for him. They walked out and they hadn't voted for him.
So the other guy wins by a tremendous amount.
Well, same story. We filed a case.
That's the one I think the government intervened on.
And the judge found after with a lengthy trial and all that stuff.
And the judge found that there's another instance of discrimination.
In fact, they didn't mean it.
And he called, he required that election to be held again.
And it was held again. And Harrison Brown won.
And was a member of the school board.
And that stopped happening up there. That was the end of that.
The elections were right after that.
And I think democracy had it played its will there as a result of the demographics.
I feel so represented Robert Hicks in a, when he came to you in concerning the pending instructions
in public housing, Bogolusa.
Yes.
And the concerns that you were able to find.
Hicks was following the plans for the construction of government public housing in Bogolusa.
And realized that by the placement of housing, they were placing the housing deep into black neighborhoods
and deep into white neighborhoods and none along the areas that might be considered mixed.
And he wanted to know whether he could stop it.
And we researched it and decided that it was a violation.
It could be said to be a violation of the non-discrimination provisions of a recently enacted news, a new civil rights act that had been enacted by then.
And I think this is 1967. There was another one, little vague on, I think this fair housing law was a separate law from the civil rights law and the voting rights law.
My memory serves me, is that right?
And we brought the suit under that.
It had never been established that any private person could sue under that.
Or that the relief we were seeking was plausible. It was available.
And we litigated that case against the federal government who had helped us in all these other cases.
I'm suing HUD and they're bringing representatives by the Department of Justice, probably by the Civil Rights Division.
And Judge Casabray found we did have a right of action and that we, it was discriminatory to do that and he enjoyed the construction of the housing.
At the last minute they had the bulldozers in ready to clear the land and the word came up from New York to Bogalosa, the judges issued an order of turn-off those bulldozers.
And they couldn't build them that way and they built them the other way as far as I remember I think they did or maybe they abandoned it.
I'm not really sure about that point but they weren't allowed to do that.
And I mentioned that to you as an example of creativity that Hicks would have in spotting every aspect of what he was trying to prevent.
And I think we talked earlier about some of the treatment of the football players and the cheerleaders and the...
The Pram.
The Pram, same kind of thing with the football players, they wouldn't let...
First they wouldn't let them on the football team and they wouldn't play them and they would only play in positions that they didn't want to play in.
We got Judge Hebe into every little detail about who's gonna... like he was the coach of the football team.
And all that was from Robert Hicks and he wasn't gonna take half a loaf and that's one of the fantastic things about the man really is that he wasn't gonna settle for part of it.
So, I suppose.
The case of Hicks against Weaver.
Hicks against Weaver.
69.
Yeah.
District Courtroom.
One of the things about welfare cases and also a case involving sweet potatoes down.
Okay.
The welfare cases.
Annie and I, my wife Annie and I and Lola C. Light became involved in representing a group of women who were being criminally prosecuted in federal court New Orleans under for charges of welfare fraud, receiving more welfare than they were entitled, welfare payments than they were entitled to.
And we...
We tried two of those cases on the facts before juries.
I'm gonna tell you the result first and then what happened along the way.
And of the 20-something women involved, one who had some prior criminal record served three months in prison in West Virginia.
And all the others didn't have any...
Any...
So it was rather successful.
I think it was kind of...
There was a plea bog in there at the end about...
After a lot of other litigation, I'm about to describe where they would...
Drop the other cases, this one woman who had this record would serve three months and know where the end of it.
But in the meantime, we dug into it and firstly we challenged the composition of the grand jury, the racial and economic composition of the jury that had issued these indictments.
Because these were very petty offenses that they were being charged with.
And did some computer work that enabled us to...
The race of the jurors was shown in the court records, but the relative poverty, non-poverty was not.
And we were able to get a hold of the food stamp, computer tapes.
These are the days of computer tapes.
And the voting roll tapes.
And have a computer determine what percentage of the people on the food stamp list were registered voters.
And it turned out that 30% of the food stamp recipients were registered to vote.
And 78% of all other people were registered to vote.
And that meant that there was not a fair cross-section of the community in the jury pool.
The authorities that be wiggled around that by reducing the figures down to a particular grand jury of seven people.
And the grand jury of 17 and deciding it would only make the difference of 1.4 persons per jury.
In other words, instead of a representation of one statistically, it would be 2.4.
That difference was not substantial.
That's the decision then.
Golf first of the United States, I cited that.
Which is pretty tricky in my mind, actually.
It had never been established at that time that there was an economic component to a fair cross-section.
But since it has been, but they didn't rule that there wasn't.
They just ruled that there wasn't enough, which, let me just say I disagree with.
Then when they went to the first trial, the prosecutor used his prectery challenges to eliminate every black person in the panel.
So that the only people who could be on the jury were white. And the jury was all white.
And we challenged the legality of the use of prectery challenges in that way.
And there was no law on that because prectery challenges had always been defined as a lawyer can get rid of anybody who wants to, doesn't have to have a reason.
And we convinced Judge Rubin, the trial judge, that he could be any reason they want except race.
And that this, the fact that he eliminated every black juror, was proof that it was race.
And he held that. And that's the reported decision called the United States versus McDaniels.
And I believe that hadn't happened before. I'm not sure of that.
But I know this that 20 years later, Supreme Court adopted that as a rule of national applicability in a case called Batson.
Where now, when a prosecutor in federal courts all over the country, if a prosecutor is disproportionate,
disproportionately removes black jurors, he has to submit in writing to the judge reasonable, non-racial reasons for that.
And as a result, prosecutors don't do it. So it was a, Vance the Bull in that way.
And I think we did okay by our clients because what I said, when they first were charged, they were all fearful of spending years in jail and they didn't have to.
That was after LCDC. See, I came back to Louisiana later on.
And, yeah.
Can you just carefully do the chronology, the basic chronology mid, say 67 forward from the end or for as good forward?
I stayed in Louisiana as employed by LCDC until, I stayed in Louisiana till August 1968.
I was employed by LCDC until December 1968.
I went to Washington where I had come from. I did not want to go back to Arnold and Porter.
I was, you can imagine, was a changed person at this point.
And I wrote, I worked at the, I had an office at the Institute for Policy Studies and I wrote my part of the article with George.
And in the meantime, I had been offered a position teaching in the University of Michigan.
And in, at the first of the year, moved out to Michigan.
I did, I didn't like January 69.
January 69.
Did not enjoy teaching.
And in addition to that, I was running the Louisiana all the time.
These cases I was handling, I never stopped in them until they were over.
And whatever in condition I was in, I was still doing these cases.
So I had a schedule of teaching Thursday and Friday, which is pretty sweet, really.
But I would leave Saturday morning and come back Wednesday night.
And I was in Louisiana at the LCDC office the whole time.
So I didn't really give it a fair chance.
And the woman I was married to at that time didn't like living in Annover.
So after one semester, I left and I went to work for Marion Edelman, Marion Wright Edelman at the,
what was then called the Washington Research Project.
And I, it wasn't then focused the way it is now.
Now it's called the Children's Defense Fund.
And now it's all about children.
But at that time, that hadn't been clarified in her mind.
And we were going to bring cases that would push the government in the right direction on civil rights.
And I did that for two years with a lot of help.
There was staff there.
There were people there.
It was much different.
And I mentioned a few of the cases in the memo I gave you.
And in 1971, I decided I would want it to be back in Louisiana.
And I moved back and that's, and soon thereafter, well, there was a divorce and are involved here.
And Ann and I came to live with me here.
And that's when we got into this welfare litigation.
And other cases, other cases.
The case against Nopsey about the bus drivers was in that period and so forth.
And then several years later in 1974, the idea of my children being in Washington and me being here kind of caught up with me.
And we moved back to Washington.
I lived there for 17 years.
I worked for Marion again for a while.
And then one of the other people in that office, Mike Tristan, I opened a law firm on our own.
And practice together, so will interest her.
Thank you for that.
Two last things and then we'll break the internship with any last thing that you might have.
I want to, even mentioned earlier, I want to make sure we talk about there was a very interesting case involving the cooperative in South Sweet Potatoes.
Okay.
The case arose out of the area of Upper Lucis, Louisiana and,
name of that town again.
Was Stanley lives?
Lafayette, Louisiana, where there is a lot of sweet potato growing.
Many of the farmers are black farmers.
And for years, they had been selling the potatoes to a white host sailor.
And much, much of the profit along the line of the potato reaching the table went to the host sailor and not to the farmer.
And a group of people, one of whom was a core representative in that area, John Zippert,
and a Catholic priest who had been assigned to a parish in that district name of Alfred McKnight, Albert McKnight.
And many of the local farmers formed a, a farm's cooperative to process package and sell the sweet potatoes.
And it became a quite resented by the powers, the white power structure, because there wasn't just one white host sailor.
There were several and they were all being adversely hurt by this.
And so the DA began to hassle them about their organization and call people before grand juries and all kinds of inappropriate things.
And one night, he had his people, had the police break into their office and take away their files.
And potentially trying to put them out of business.
And the case came to us.
And we sued in federal court in Lafayette to, I guess you'd say prohibit, to join the conduct and to return the documents.
And the district attorney had to come in to federal court and explain what he was doing.
And he was unable to do that.
And the judges shoot an injunction prohibiting them from having any contact with this organization.
And the organization is still there.
It's called the Southern consumers.
I forgot the name.
So it's got the other word, Southern consumers cooperative.
And there's one more word in it.
But it's, and the word's not potato.
It's some other word.
But anyway, it's something there.
And they're still doing it.
They're still handling their own host sailing.
And so that was just a thing.
It got me over to Lafayette.
I'd never been there before.
I didn't, we didn't have activity in Lafayette.
And got to see what was going on there.
And as a result, got to be friends with John Siprit, who was the core worker there.
A white man who was wanting to marry one of the young ladies he had met out there named Carol Prasion.
And the clerk of court wouldn't give him a marriage license, because there was mixed race.
And the Supreme Court had just decided loving against Virginia.
I walled in there with my suit to join me to require the
clerk of court to give him a marriage license.
And of course, he did.
I got to go to the wedding.
It was a happy occasion all around.
Well, last thing, you mentioned that we should stop.
Let's know if you can get immediate.
I feel out of respect for all that you accomplished.
It's really nice to have some of this more extensive records set down.
So even if we're touching that in modest ways, the scope of it is another way to make the fun of the civil.
And another angle of perspective maybe.
And we're going there.
My final question.
You mentioned, and thank you for all your patience.
You were very long in the room.
You mentioned one point that, you know, on return to when you moved away from Louis Vuitton.
In the late 60s that you kind of left to change person.
And maybe just some reflections on yourself.
Others you saw.
Move through these very.
To mulch you us and involving years on this issue.
And your perspective on how that did change you and the things that.
How you added the world differently.
Okay.
Let me say first something which I kind of passed over at the beginning.
I mentioned that I didn't think these volunteer lawyers were earning their keep in terms of the cost to send them.
But one thing which is undeniable is after being here for two or three or four weeks,
they go back home and it would change their lives.
And I, to this day, I'm hearing stories about lawyers who spent a short period of time either here or in Jackson or in Alabama.
And they are the head of the Human Rights Commission in Pittsburgh or Cincinnati or something of that sort.
And it really was like a contagion.
I got a very big dose.
But even for those smaller doses it was like a contagion and it's remarkable.
And this is true of the law students as well who would come down.
There was a group called law students civil committee for civil rights.
It was a listric.
And the law students were also changed and went into public service work or pro bono work.
So I just wanted to mention that because what you said.
I had been through all these experiences and not just legal but social.
And we haven't mentioned the Vietnam War but that was coming.
That was going on and I was meeting and spending time with anti-war activists and felt strongly about that too.
And I got to the point that I could just see that there was what I was interested in.
And I couldn't just see going back to a firm and being slaughtered into some anti-trust case representing one big corporation against another.
It just, by the time the two years was over I just knew I was going to do work in this area.
Not some other, you know, not a commercial area.
And I was very lucky to be able to do that actually.
Not only do it but do it on my own terms and my own law firm.
And the reason were these two union lawyers I mentioned to you before made it possible because they really got me into having a billing client.
All this stuff I've ever done in Louisiana.
And there's never, no one's ever paid anything for it except if you win a title seven case the court makes the defendant pay you which is nice.
But in terms of sustaining a law practice that's not a very good way to go about it.
So I felt I wanted to do that and I feel I was very lucky to be able to do that.
I don't know what else to say about it. It's just your mind is different.
When I left Donald and Porter I wanted that leave of absence. I wanted that security that I could come back and I wasn't going to be floating out there without a job.
And then by the first year was up I was kind of not so concerned about it although they extended it.
At the end of the second year it was just completely out of the question.
I had argued in the Supreme Court.
These are these young lawyers.
These big firms they go their whole lives and they're wrong.
They're going to scream, go on and win.
So it just was just expanded by it and was able to pursue it.
Thank you.
Jim. Jim.
I do want to get in.
Sure.
Okay, what's Porter?
From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.